scheiß ja ich dann immer so aber er sagt
jetzt bestimmt war oder junge entweder
zu machen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge war oder
ok das recht okay er hat gesagt er steht
auf mich
wir haben
entschieden und wir klären das jetzt und
wir haben natürlich die professionellste
guck da die profession wo war denn
unentschieden wir hatten alle die
gleiche werden alle vier bücher
ach ja stimmt meine bisher war nicht
mehr da wir haben jetzt gesagt magische
miesmuschel macht das genau und setzte
lasst euch einfach
ihr werdet schon sehen wie wir das
machen also die magische miesmuschel
hochprofessionell wieder bei aber jetzt
die sache ist die magische miesmuscheln
app bei mir kann man einstellen die
positive negative oder neutrale antwort
ja du hast ja auch vertrauen ja gut dann
finde ich das mal besonders wenig ändern
so ist crafter platz 1 ausgeschlossen
junge du veränderst dass er platz eins
ganz
sicher nicht
ja weil du vielleicht nur negativ
eingestellt habe
das
behindert worauf ich gewonnen habe ich
mal meine app an ich mache meine
miesmuschel es
[Gelächter]
so ich habe alles eingestellt
los geht's wir machen doch wir machen
noch ein durchgang wenn jetzt mal
gewinnt dann hat man erhält gewonnen
wenn andere gewittergefahr
[Musik]
losgeht
hat manuel gewonnen
ja das
hat malte gewonnen
hat luca gewonnen
nur halt dein maul das sind da nicht
nachlassen und
die behinderte wert gewonnen
so
mancher dass wir alle reisen linke
bekommen das ist so fair und man nicht
halten
[Gelächter]
was hat er denn eine magische
miesmuschel für eine behinderte stimme
man jetzt so gut okay dann kommt jetzt
in der bildung ein ja ok los gehts jungs
sagen wir vorher das soll von der
community sind
die die die sind nicht von der community
sind ich fang dir ich sage ich immer
dass steuer ist jetzt von einer
community
nötig sagt das nicht wenn das von der
community ist so einem pisser alter
[Musik]
gut
also dass war hatte ich nur kurz einen
schluck trinken
ja also
folgen
das war bisschen in der schule im
unterricht der siebten klasse und wir
hatten das mathe unterricht
naja
jeder natürlich in der klasse 1 gestört
wurde meine klasse nicht ausgelassen und
ich sage jetzt nicht den namen aber xy
kies der kleine vix kobold ok auf jeden
fall musste der lehrer im unterricht
kurz in der city rad um etwas zu klären
doch da dachte sich der kleine
wieso wählen weil wie so wichtig mir
nicht einen und wisch ist am lehrertisch
ab
und konnte den ekelhaften vorgang mit
ansehen
aber als der lehrer nach circa fünf
minuten noch nicht da war war ja zum
schussbereit stand auf und erklärte auf
den tisch danach setzte er sich wieder
hin denn wer kam rein und wir macht
gemütlich den unterricht war ich
natürlich patch ist irgendwann ein
schüler und der fix aber kann schön am 8
der weg soll
danach im matheunterricht er gewinnt
also ja also also einer aus meiner
klasse
adams okay
[Gelächter]
ob diese typen in der klasse da war
[Musik]
okay gut ich glaube das nicht ich hoffe
dass das nicht ich hoffe auch das stimmt
nicht aber ich verkaufe das ist falsch
sagt
ein junger alter
[Musik]
meine story das ist aber ich kann
meine story nummer 1
also
ich war damals so eine hochzeit wie
glaube ich jeder irgendwie schon
und da ist es ja mal so dass die braut
am ende dann den den strauß so hinter
sich so wirft und blabla und die und wir
mussten halt fangen ja natürlich und der
ehemann hat einen magneten in den strauß
gemacht
hat einen magneten in den strassen ganz
starken und noch eine
laterne ein
[Musik]
leuchter und die braut wirft einfach den
strauß hoch und er wird einfach magisch
angezogen von hatten leuchten dann hängt
dieser strauß da an diesen diesen
leuchter und
legenden sagen dass er da heute noch
hängt aber
wahr oder falsch war immer älter was
mussten das bitte für nied gewesen sein
naja ich hab grad gefallen das musste ja
der ultimative magnet ich sage das ist
falsch der fall wäre das wahrscheinlich
denn so schwer gewesen
ja ich sag mal so war
wie
hast du das von wem von jan moritz
becker ex captain
ich hasse ich den namen die man nicht
aussprechen kann aber
ich will die umsetzung sehen das gern so
muss ich mal eben hier wieder mit video
also meine story ist eklig
[Gelächter]
astrium gelaufen
nein
ich war beim kumpel und er musste
richtig scheiße
und der ist dann halt karten gegangen
und irgendwie hat die schwerter kanada
ist man das 1
ich habe
ein stück
abgespielt dann wird sie mal zu boden
dann einfach nur die klobürste genommen
dass er so rein gedrückt in den abfluss
die klobürste zurückgestellt hat aber
nicht geguckt ob danach scheiße da
war so wie wir ich hoffe herr der war
scheiße der hat gekackt die spülung
gegen nicht und dann hat er einfach
logisch oder herumgestochert und dann
war fertig
kannst du die moderne wie du mir mit
meinem finger
kann die mutter nach hause
reinigen die eklige du bist plötzlich
nach seiner oper geglänzt hat hört er
fände es mir nochmals gibt übrig sagt
rasch es bei
das falsch
nein ich würde sagen ich bin so dumm
[Musik]
scheiß ja ich denke dann immer so alle
sagt jetzt bestimmt war junge entweder
zu machen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
diesmal hinzu das muss hier diskret
ablaufen okay okay und zwar schon ein
paar kollegen bei den kumpeln und wir
haben gefeiert
und dann komischerweise war mir
irgendwie schon um zwei uhr morgens
übertrieben dich
und wir haben so einen kollegen der
verträgt halt gar nichts an alkohol
verträgt einfach nichts
bei dem man doch zu hause ja
und wir saßen am esstisch
und
[Gelächter]
fängt an in sein zimmer zu wissen
das gefühl war
[Musik]
roth hält den schluss war
ich weit weg wie viele bücher hast du
und den blazer der 2
naja ich hoffe die jungs also den place
hatten wir den scheiß geschickt day of
scale also die mails sind übrigens wie
man in der beschreibung
also ein kumpel von mir hat sich seine
bananen frau gesteckt weil sich halt ich
halt ich habe auch spaß gemeint wir
waren halt alle auch so ein bisschen
blau ich habe auch spaß gemeint dass der
schule ist
dann habe ich gesagt dass ich eine
banane ins ohr stecken soll und
dass er damit dann beweist dass er nicht
schwul ist weil er dann keine latte
bekommt dann dann lief der tatsächlich
mit einer banane im ohr im kreis rum und
der drei mal gerufen ich bin nicht
schwul du sagt ich bin nicht schwul und
sagte ich bin nicht schwul du sack und
dabei ist er dann irgendwie gestolpert
und mit der banane dann auf dem boden
und damit die banane und teile davon
musste nachher von einem arzt rausgeholt
werden
hat er sich die banane so kraft ins ohr
gesteckt man also nadja fest schnee so
einfach so banane ist ein bisschen war
ich dass ich dann wieder so reingesteckt
man halt haider drinnen dann hat er sich
so gemeinden irgendeins trommelfell
gekommen also das ist richtig abartig
gewesen der zugeschrieben
ich sage das war
ja
scheiße ich habe die ich habe das gerade
wieder gelöscht das bild ich weiß nicht
von wem sie kommt aber wenn wenn du wenn
du das war war blabla war der community
nachricht sorry dass ich jetzt nicht
reden tut mir leid
klima schlecht nicht gut heißt es jetzt
zähle ich jetzt eine geschichte liebe
kinder
na gut ich geh da runter also ich war
als ich kann nicht lügen elf oder zwölf
geht weg von mir
als kumpel draußen auf der straße
spielen oder zu verschenken gezockt mit
dem
wenn ihr bruder von dem ich habe mich in
der mülltonne versteckt die
papiermülltonne
das ist versuch sollte die einfach mal
nach hause gelaufen die boutique
anhalt an und hat sich da so an der
milch schon ein bisschen angelehnt und
fertig war raus na ja die ganze zeit mit
einer freundin telefoniert und er wird
bestimmt so 20 minuten in der mülltonne
hat und ich muss aber zugeben dass das
spiel geworden
ich sag ja
[Musik]
ich habe drei ich habe vor alter halte
doch jetzt hab ich schon wieder verloren
habe
ich finde dich alter von bauder falsch
dass sie kein dialog
via blog nein an der stein ein diamant
krank
junge ich bin der weltmeister
junge wenn die kiste voll es muss irgend
eine bestrafung machen
da nicht bestrafen lassen das einfach
einfach sein wird wir strahlen ein der
verlierer dass ich doch gleichzeitig ja
ja deswegen der verlierer der die
von klima
nächste runde kommt wieder bei uns auf
dem channel und
den montag darauf steht wieder beim
crafter
immer weiter
ich könnte es nicht verhindern
gewalt und zwischenhoch geben und halt
ja und schickt immer nur einer person
von ja wirklich auch noch sein okay das
war's mit dem building hat drei noch
wiedersehen typen